der jetzt auch das thema max otte als
kandidat für die bundespräsidentenwahl
hier vertiefen wird und zwar mit beatrix
von storch stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende der fdp im
bundestag da haben wir einen richtigen
kugel landet es kommt ja relativ selten
vor dass in einer bundesversammlung ein
kandidat antritt für eine partei und ist
in wirklichkeit mitglied einer ganz
anderen partei wie groß ist ihre
schadenfreude dass sie max otte da
gewinnen konnten dass es keine
schadenfreude wir machen der cdu ein
angebot einen ihrer mitglieder zu wählen
max otte ist festes mitglied der cdu und
die cdu hat sich entschieden nicht nur
bei dieser bundesversammlung aber eben
auch die rolle der opposition nicht
wahrzunehmen sie stellen keinen eigenen
kandidaten auf sie haben jetzt aber die
gelegenheit einen aus ihren reihen zu
wählen das ist professor max otte und
insofern sind wir gespannt wer dieses
angebot annehmen wird max otte hat ja
auch hat einige cdu delegierte
geschrieben und sich als eigentlicher
bürgerlicher gegenkandidat der
unionsparteien da präsentiert die union
hat aber niemanden aufgestellt sie will
den amtsinhaber wieder wählen damit
würde ja jetzt auch der frisch gewählte
parteivorsitzende friedrich merz
beschädigt glauben sie dass sich so
viele cdu delegierte gewinnen die dann
selbstmord begehen aus angst vor dem tod
also wir sehen auf jeden fall dass die
cdu in der opposition ein totalausfall
ist und zwar in jeder denkbaren hinsicht
und hier hätten sie die möglichkeit
gehabt einen akzent zu setzen sie
verzichtet daraus wir geben ihnen jetzt
aber die möglichkeit eben doch
vielleicht ein signal zu senden und wer
das möchte der kann das jetzt gleich tun
es ist eine geheime wahl wir werden
sehen was dabei rauskommt aber ich
glaube das wichtige ist es zu sehen dass
die afd bereit ist auch über die
parteigrenzen hinweg zusammenzuarbeiten
angebote zu machen da wo von der anderen
seite etwas gutes kommt oder sie einen
guten kandidaten haben dann stellen wir
den auf und unterstützen diese inhalte
das heißt das ist konstruktive
oppositionspolitik dafür stehen wir und
dafür stehen wir auch heute in dieser
bundesversammlung ob sie dass die cdu
diese signale erwidern wird das werden
wir sehen sie tun sich im moment noch
ein bisschen schwer aber ich glaube wenn
in dem weiteren verlauf dieser
legislaturperiode klar wird dass die
tatsächliche inhaltliche opposition zu
dieser ampel regierung aus unseren
reihen kommt dann wird man ende sehen
wir da wie mit wählerstimmen belohnt
wird im moment geht es darum
festzustellen dass die cdu ein
totalausfall ist in dieser opposition
und wir werden gerne helfen wir da eine
brücke zu bauen und wir sind bereit auch
cdu kandidaten zu unterstützen ich
gesagt habe allerdings gibt es signale
aus der cdu moment ja tatsächlich nicht
was würde eigentlich mit einer
mit einem mitglied der asd passieren
dass bei der bundesversammlung für eine
andere partei als kandidat oder
kandidatinnen zur wahl des
bundespräsidenten antritt sie wissen
dass theoretische fragen immer nicht
beantwortet werden die cdu ist die
gestellt werden dass die cdu das macht
das ist nicht in unserer das ist nicht
in unserer macht der otter hat gesagt er
ist fester bestandteil der cdu hat sich
von der cdu nicht distanziert insofern
könnten in die cdu csu mitglieder auch
wählen es ist ein mann aus ihrer mitte
nicht aus unserer dass er der professor
otte sehr klar gesagt er will als
überparteilicher kandidat antreten das
ist ein angebot der zusammenarbeit mal
schauen wie er es annimmt mal gucken ob
diese taktik oder auch diese strategie
aufgeht so weit vertritt von storch im
interview hier in phoenix vielen dank
dass sie da aber an